je m'avisais de faire une revue sur les
diverses occupations qu'on les hommes en
cette vie pour ta chair faire choix de
la meilleure et sans que je veuille rien
dire de celle des autres je pensais que
je ne pouvais mieux que de continuer en
sel la même où je me trouvais
c'est-à-dire que d'employer toute ma vie
à cultiver ma raison et m'avancer autant
que je pourrai en la connaissance de la
vérité suivant la méthode que je m'étais
prescrite voici donc un bref extrait du
discours de la méthode de René Descartes
ce livre écrit en 1637 est considéré
comme l'ouvrage référence de la
philosophie moderne René Descartes est
né ici dans le sud de l'Indre-et-Loire
en 1596 dans une commune qui porte alors
le nom de l'ail en Touraine avant de
devenir la haie Descartes à la
Révolution puis Descartes tout court en
1967 c'est dans la maison René Descartes
avec son médiateur culturel que nous
allons maintenant nous rendre sur les
traces de l'une des plus illustre
figures littéraires et scientifiques du
XVIIe siècle
on y va Thomas on y va
elle a du caractère cette maison Thomas
oui tout à fait c'est une maison
d'habitation du 16e siècle qui a
appartenu à la grand-mère maternelle de
René Descartes
alors voilà la statue de cire de René
Descartes homme mature déjà on est dans
la maison et vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure de la grand-mère maternelle
pourquoi justement la naissance ici de
René Descartes dans cette maison-ci en
effet donc sa famille est originaire de
Châtellerault mais à cette époque là les
femmes avaient pour habitude d'accoucher
donc dans la maison de leur de leur mère
de leurs parents et donc c'est ici que
Jeanne Brochard et bien va faire toutes
ses couches et va donner naissance donc
aux frères et sœurs et bien de René
Descartes et que sait-on finalement de
cet enfant heureuse malheureuse dans ce
sud de l'Indre-et-Loire pour René
Descartes sa mère meurt lorsqu'il a un
petit peu plus d'un an et donc il est
élevé en partie dans cette maison ici
par sa grand-mère et il est très entouré
et sa grand-mère le baigne d'affection
alors nous sommes montés à l'étage et a
priori cette pièce ceci pourrait être
justement le lieu de naissance de René
Descartes oui tout à fait selon la
légende et bien René Descartes serait né
ici dans cette pièce au premier étage et
aussi on peut l'imaginer très
certainement auprès de cette cheminée
parce qu'il était de santé fragile et
donc il pouvait très certainement venir
se réchauffer ici auprès de Lattre alors
petite anecdote supplémentaire nous
avons ici donc le moulage du crâne de
Descartes donc une copie dont l'original
est au Musée de l'Homme à Paris avec de
nombreuses inscriptions sur le crâne oui
en fait ce sont des inscriptions qui ont
été écrites par les propriétaires
successifs
[Musique]
on a quitté des cartes pour se retrouver
ici devant l'université de Tours où nous
attend Laurent Gerbier de la Faculté de
Philosophie afin de comprendre pourquoi
ce livre écrit en 1637 est toujours
important aujourd'hui même au 21e siècle
il a un rôle fondateur non pas au sens
où après des cartes tout le monde serait
d'accord avec des cartes il a un rôle
fondateur au sens où après Descartes on
ne pourra disputer qu'à partir de
Descartes que ce soit pour être d'accord
ou pas de ce point de vue là la réponse
la plus simple consiste à dire que c'est
le livre qui va créer les conditions du
débat philosophique et scientifiques au
moins jusqu'à l'Encyclopédie de Diderot
et d'Alembert à la fin du XVIIIe siècle
on en est à 400 ans au quasiment du
Discours de la méthode qu'est-ce qu'il
en reste aujourd'hui il y a cette
fameuse expression qu'on utilise tous
c'est un peu galvaudé l'esprit cartésien
c'est quoi l'esprit cartésien d'ailleurs
alors l'esprit cartésien avant tout
c'est le signe d'un succès vous savez
qu'il y a pas beaucoup d'auteurs qui ont
eu cette honneur de voir leur nom propre
se transformer en nom commun dans Kafka
Gargantua par un auteur mais la créature
d'un auteur et Descartes et donc on nous
français on serait tous cartésien la
première chose qu'il faut rappeler c'est
que c'est une invention du 19e siècle
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait l'université
française telle qu'elle se structure au
19e siècle de Descartes la grande
référence de l'histoire philosophique
nationale le grand philosophe national
et c'est donc au 19e siècle on commence
à dire en fait nous sommes tous
cartésiens je pense qu'on peut
identifier autour de cette idée de
l'esprit cartésien autour de cette
conception qui dirait que les Français
sont tous des cartésiens un certain
rapport à la raison comme universelle
d'une part et comme alternative aux
autorités théologiques d'autre part
parce que ce dont on se souvient au XIXe
siècle quand on affirme l'esprit
cartésien on n'est pas très loin de la
loi de 1905 on n'est pas très loin des
grands affrontements entre la République
et l'église ce dont on se souvient c'est
que Descartes c'est celui qui a dit on
n'a pas besoin de la religion on n'a pas
besoin de la foire on n'a pas besoin des
autorités théologiques pour utiliser la
raison ça reste un objet absolument
central des études de philosophie dès la
terminale et évidemment dans les
universités philosophiques mais ce qui
est intéressant peut-être c'est de
constater que de manière très régulière
y compris dans des disciplines qui sont
pas la philosophie je pense par exemple
aux neurosciences Descartes est un objet
que l'on attaque et au fond la meilleure
preuve du fait qu'il est encore vivant
c'est qu'il y a dans d'autres sciences
des gens qui ont encore besoin de dire
qu'il avait tort
[Musique]
prenez Descartes meurt en 1650 en Suède
il s'y rend pour donner des cours de
philosophie à la reine Christine il fait
très froid à Stockholm cette année là
des cartes meurent des suites d'une
pneumonie dans sa 54e année